fort mcmurray
being evacuated has been
extremely difficult canada is a country
where we look out for our neighbors and
we were there are there for each other
in difficult times today on parliament
hill prime minister justin trudeau
offers canada's helping hand to those in
alberta affected by the fort mcmurray
wildfire that forced a total evacuation
houses the whole city like gone walk out
the earth sarah blackwood is in shock
really devastating to see something like
that happening somewhere that's really
close to you it's scary and i really
feel for
everybody that's
being affected the fire has captured the
attention of some of canada's biggest
stars tegan and sarah biff naked johnny
reed george canyon paul brandt dragon's
den brett wilson and arlene dickinson
are all sending messages to support on
social media and encouraging canadians
to donate to red cross the difficult
times they're going through right now is
something that we're going to unite
around across the country and even the
queen is standing by fort mcmurray's
side releasing this statement our
thoughts and prayers are with all those
who have been affected and we send our
heartfelt thanks to the firefighters and
the emergency workers